hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve a problem
meeting rooms and you notice that the ui
of this looks a little bit different and
let me show you why
so if you go on leak code and you try to
solve this problem meeting rooms you'll
notice that
it's a locked problem and you have to
subscribe and pay money to be able to
solve this premium really good problem
but there's actually a workaround that i
found
and that is that there's a site called
lint code
and on that site lint code you can
basically solve
it's it's pretty much a leak code clone
and you can basically solve
premium leak code problems for free so
you know this
is so yeah if you don't want to pay
money to be able to solve certain
problems on leak code i'd recommend
solving them on this site instead so
that's what i'm going to be doing today
but nevertheless this is basically the
exact same problem i don't know how they
can get away with doing that but that's
okay
so we're given an array of meeting time
intervals consisting of start and end
time so each
interval is basically a tuple or a pair
of values the first value is the start
time the second value is the end time
of a particular meeting so for example
if we were given two meetings one starts
at zero and
ends at eight and the next one starts at
eight and ends at
ten these do not overlap basically we're
trying to determine if a person could
attend both of these meetings and
technically they could
because it's one ends at eight and the
other one starts at eight so that's
technically
non-overlapping and in this case we
would return true because
the person could attend both of these
meetings but let's look at the second
example
so we see that one meeting starts at
zero and ends at thirty
the next meeting that starts after it
starts at five so
technically it starts after this meeting
but it ends
at 10. so the main thing to notice is
this meeting
starts before this meeting has even
ended right so if this goes from zero
all the way
to thirty we see another meeting starts
over here at
five and it goes to ten but the thing
we're paying attention to is it started
before the other meeting even
ended right like we can see that they
are overlapping therefore nobody could
be able to attend both of the meetings
at the same time so we have to return
false because we found
overlapping intervals so as you can tell
it might be helpful for us if we're able
to sort
all of the meetings based on the start
time
of each meeting and they basically gave
us that
sorted array you know just as an input
but and they're basically hinting us
to do exactly that sort it based on the
start value of each
interval so if we we are given an array
of meeting intervals and we sort based
on the start time that is going to take
n log n complexity for that sorting
but after we're done sorting what you're
going to notice is we're basically
allowed to start at the beginning and
just scan
through so the next part of the
algorithm is going to be o of n
so the overall time complexity is just
going to be big o and log n
so what we're going to do is we're going
to look at the first
two intervals available to us and the
only thing we're going to compare
is the end time of the first interval
and the start time of the second
interval because we
know for sure since these are in sorted
order this one is going to start
before or equal to the same time as this
one so we know for sure the start time
of this is either going to be right here
or it's going to come after it and for
us to detect
that these two intervals are overlapping
it's very simple
if the start time of this is before the
end
time of this one that means they are
overlapping so for example if the start
time of this was over here
that means it starts before this one
ends therefore
they are overlapping and we can
immediately return false right that
means no one could attend all of the
meetings
but if they're not overlapping which is
the case right now right
this one starts right as this one ends
so that technically does not mean that
they're overlapping
so that means these two intervals are
not overlapping
so my next question to you is does that
mean now we have to compare this one
to this one as well we don't and that's
exactly why we sorted the input because
do we know
if this one if this interval starting
value came after
or equal to this interval's n value then
there's no
way that this interval could possibly
overlap with this one because we know
for sure
this interval start time is going to
come after this interval start time
right
or equal to it so if this one did not
overlap this one then there's no way
this could possibly overlap this one so
we don't have to check that so now
as we move to the next position we're
going to be checking if
these two intervals are overlapping
and so again we're just going to repeat
that process okay the end time of this
one and the start time of this one well
this the start time of this is after
this one
after the end time of this interval so
therefore they're definitely not
overlapping right
and if this one does not overlap with
this one if we had a bunch of intervals
that came after over here right even if
they started at the exact same time
right maybe some intervals like this
then if we can determine that
this interval does not overlap this
interval then for sure
all of these intervals that could
possibly exist towards the right
are definitely not going to overlap with
this one either
so then we just continue our comparisons
comparing
each adjacent pair of intervals so that
is basically the solution the main idea
to notice
is that we can sort the input based on
the start time and
that's going to give us the most
efficient solution so now let's jump
into the code
on lint code rather than leak code this
time so one thing before i start coding
is i want to mention that the list of
intervals is given to us not as a pair
but it's actually an
object so interval happens to be an
object it has two members
start and end and they basically mean
what they say they mean
so now we can code it so remember the
first thing we're going to want to do is
sort the intervals and we're going to
sort it based on the start time so in
python we can give the key that we're
going to be sorting on
as this it's going to be lambda
basically an inline function
so for this function if we're given an
input i for the interval
the return value or rather what we're
going to be sorting it based on
is going to be i of start right so for
an interval we're going to be sorting it
based on the start time
of that interval and once we're done
with that we're just going to iterate
through the entire
array of intervals so i'm going to
use i for index it's not the interval
itself and we're going to go through the
length of intervals and since we're
comparing adjacent intervals
we can actually start at index 1 because
we're going to compare
index 1 with the previous index so we're
going to be looking at two intervals
interval 1
is going to be the interval at index i
minus 1. so that's going to be the first
interval interval 2 is going to be
the interval at the current index or
intervals at index
i and remember we want to compare the
end time of interval 1 and the start
time of interval 2 and how are we
comparing them how do we know if we're
going to be returning
false if and only if the start time
of interval 2 is less than the
end time of interval 1 that means
interval 2 starts before interval 1
ends and therefore we would have to
return false
if that's not the case though then we
don't have to do anything right then we
just have to go to the next iteration of
our loop and then compare the next two
intervals
and if we never end up returning false
that means we
never had overlapping intervals then we
can just return true as soon as we exit
out of the loop
so now let me just submit it make sure
that it works
and yep you can see it's about as
efficient as we could get so
uh probably the biggest thing that you
learned in this is that you can use a
website called link code to solve
premium leak code problems for free
and i think i'm probably going to be
making use of this site when i'm solving
some other premium questions such as
alien dictionary and some other ones
that i think are pretty important and
good problems to practice
so i hope that this was helpful if it
was please like and subscribe it
supports the channel a lot and i'll
hopefully
see you pretty soon thanks for watching